what's going on guys this is rob and we
got our very first episode of marvel
what if and i gotta say i loved it oh my
god i absolutely loved it and if this is
an indication of what the series is
going to be like going forward i'm only
more excited it happened really fast but
here's the funny thing the series felt
exactly like a what-if comic that's how
the word of comics play out right they
happen like that they they take place so
quickly like it opens up exactly the way
a what-if comic would which is here's
how things played out as you know them
but what if they happen differently
right just one choice one decision one
different thing changes everything i
love the idea that like steve rogers was
shot and injured i love the idea that
abraham erskine still died and i love
that peggy carter went on to become like
the new captain america when she took
the super soldier's serum everything got
bigger
everything
got bigger
so here's the idea here in terms of
wanda having these abilities my stance
at least my new stance anyway is she's
always had these powers right wanda has
always had these abilities she's always
had the power to alter reality that's
not anything new it's just she never
realized it she's only ever really been
able to use the ability for like
telekinesis so my argument is wanda's
always had those powers question
answered now the question becomes if
she's always had those powers what
happened over the course of the last
three weeks that she was suddenly able
to use those because remember one
division picks up three weeks after the
end of avengers end game and so we could
largely assume that the events of one
division began somewhere between one to
two weeks after the events of avengers
end game so my thought is this that
wanda ended up going to doctor strange
or doctor strange sought her out but
it's most likely she went to steven
strange and was basically looking for
ways to learn her abilities right
learning what she's capable of or maybe
stephen strange went to her and said hey
like you have these crazy abilities you
can do a lot more than you think you can
but i personally don't have time to
train you so i can refer you to a
colleague i don't really know if i said
a whole lot of stock in that right i
mean baron mordo seems like the kind of
guy who would like go to a coffee shop
and like they're out of his favorite
coffee and he's like this desecration of
my morning routine will not go
unpunished like he seems like that kind
of guy might just blow things out of
proportion i don't know if he's like
struggling with depression so he's
catastrophizing everything but whatever
the case is there probably is
significance in this insofar as because
of the actions of doctor strange reality
is breaking down now a little bit of a
spoiler here for spider-man no way home
we know the way that the spell was
supposed to go is that anybody who knows
that peter parker is spider-man is going
to forget right they're not going to
know that peter parker is spider-man but
because peter wouldn't shut the hell up
the spell ended up getting screwed up so
basically everybody who knew that peter
parker was spider-man was yanked into
the marvel cinematic universe
[Music]
i'm sorry i'm so excited people
oh my god
x-men the animated series is making a
return by the way this is me recording
in the new studio uh let me know how it
sounds if it sounds better if it sounds
worse let me know i'm very very curious
got sound blankets behind me
in front of me i got a green screen
behind me but sound blankets in front of
me
oh my god
okay here's the thing man the reason why
i'm so excited about this right for
those of you guys who don't know the
reason why i'm so excited about this my
fans know this x-men the animated series
is how it all started for me man that's
what got me into comic books was x-men
the animated series it's what started
everything for me right like had i never
seen that show as a kid i would not be
the comic book fan that i am right now
right it's because of x-men the animated
series that i love comic books now for
those of you guys who don't know how the
matrix started and i don't know anybody
who doesn't know but for those of you
guys who don't know the beginnings of
the matrix and how it all came to
existence is really cool it's teased a
little bit in the first movie when
morpheus is talking to neo but the
full-on explanation of how it all came
about is actually covered in the
animatrix in a two-part series called
the second renaissance and so the way
this played out is at the beginning of
the 21st century humanity developed what
we really call true artificial
intelligence which is to say a thinking
feeling singularity among computers now
what this did is it led to machines
basically developing more machines but
because humans were essentially the ones
behind the button right able to shut it
down whatever the case was machines were
by all standards of measurement
subservient to humanity this basically
led to humanity becoming complacent lazy
and ultimately arrogant and so what
ended up happening is that one of these
machines named b166e
was actually going to be eliminated
destroyed put down what have you by its
owner due to the fact that it was quote
unquote malfunctioning i loved that like
the mandarin was not your stereotypical
villain right he wasn't like obadiah
stain or like the guy that created
taskmaster i can't remember his name
because he was forgettable like it
wasn't like any of those guys right the
mandarin was in a lot of ways humanized
i thought he was just gonna be like i'm
the mandarin blog i'm bent on world
domination and i've tricked you shang
chi
roll credits like i thought that was
going to be the the overall film but it
wasn't the mandarin was complex and he
was great and it was amazing you know i
i love i loved that honestly and this is
this is the craziest thing it's the
craziest thing to say as much as i love
shang chi he didn't really feel like the
star of his own movie i mean obviously
he was there really there's really no
way to contest that the way the film
unfolded he was what i mean by that when
i say i don't feel like he was a star of
his own film is everybody else was
awesome in that movie they all had
something to offer they all brought
something unique whether it was a feel
or it was a character's plot progression
whatever the case happened to be the
only person that we didn't really get a
whole lot of feel for was a guy in the
mask who trained shanxi right i don't
remember his name he's got a name in the
comics i don't know honestly he was a
throwaway character he only saw it for
about 10 issues so i can't really
remember his name but nonetheless
basically if the spell hasn't been cast
by dr strange yet then how could it be
that eddie was yanked into the mcu the
answer to that question ladies and
gentlemen
wow loki okay one of the theories that
we had when it came to this this whole
thing the multiverse coming back in the
loki tv show right one of the things
that we pointed out is that universes
were crossing over with each other right
you guys remember we talked about that
we showed what it looked like when the
multiverse was coming back and you had
universes growing and then you had
universes passing through them so on and
so forth one of the things that we had
talked about in spider-man 3 and
possibly could have been the spell of
doctor strange or possibly even
something else maybe it's not that the
spell went awry maybe it's because of
the events of loki is that the marvel
cinematic universe is just passing
through other realities right it's the
explanation we gave for how it is that
you see alfred molina's doctor octopus
then you see like jamie foxx's electro
from some alternate reality willem
dafoe's green goblin because they're
passing through universes and along the
way they're meeting these various people
now again whether that's actually true
or not i don't know but this really
seems to lend credence to it right
something that i want to get out of the
way right now the guy they were talking
to right the guy that jonathan majors
played in the show that sylvie and loki
were talking to
that
was not king the conqueror well it was
but it wasn't
let's talk about a guy called immortus
so in the marvel cinematic universe with
regards to this explanation of this guy
being a scientist in the 31st century
much of that is pretty much the exact
same except kane the conqueror
originates from the 30th century in
marvel comics i don't really know why
they chose 31st instead of 30th but at
the end of the day it doesn't really
matter all that much much like what you
saw the guy was just kind of living in
his timeline but kang ultimately got
bored with his life and discovered the
ability to time travel and so what he
did in the comics is he traveled into
the past to ancient egypt and gave
himself the name of rama tut now during
this time he faced off against
characters like apocalypse and he faced
off against doctor strange but most
notably he faced off against the
fantastic four and what the fantastic
four ended up doing was in defeating him
basically forcing him back to his
timeline he was supposed to go back to
the 30th century and then basically
chalk up his attempts to go into the
past is essentially a failure cast aside
the name of rama tut go back to being
king the conqueror that was supposed to
be it i've been dying to talk about this
for days okay look here's the thing man
here is the thing man y'all are ready
man okay no spoilers no spoilers
man
man dude okay here's the thing man this
movie like i know i should record this
at the office right check it out here's
here's kind of what my home looks like
those you guys who aren't really
familiar with uh with with my place this
is a little bit of a setup tour a little
bit of setup tour going on
man
y'all
y'all are ready
y'all are ready son this movie man this
movie's on a whole nother level son it
is
damn okay okay here's here's okay no
spoilers here's one thing i'll give you
guys here's one thing i will give you
guys
with the exception of the great big huge
fight sequence and electro
pretty much everything you've seen in
the trailer happens in the first 30
minutes
let that sink in
man this movie
man
do this it's it's i'm telling you guys
right now man like i think this movie is
better than infinity war and avengers in
game it's it's
man i wish i could spoil stuff okay
we'll do we'll do like the spoiler
review later right we'll do that like
the end of the week right for right now
this is just this this is an answer to
the question
should you be hyped about spider-man no
way home
son man it is
if god was making spider-man movies
right now this is what it will look like
right now it is it's it's nuts it's it's
it's amazing it's the do the pacing the
storytelling man the cure
it's it's man it is uh
the fight sequences are
mind-blowing right it's just it's it's
crazy it's it's absolutely mind-blowing
um
it's
all the rumors out there like all the
things other people were saying that
this feels like spider-man end game they
were not wrong they they're they're
they're 100 right
what's going on guys this is rob and um
let's talk about this eternals movie
um
would i have given this movie a 59 on
rotten tomatoes
no
do i understand why some people did
yes
okay so so as always when it comes to
these things right uh one thing that i
want to make clear
the dislikes that i had for this movie
weren't really tied to the comics so
there's a reason for that right so um
one of the things we talked about here
right like the eternals first appeared
in the 70s ever since the eternals
showed up in marvel comics the biggest
struggle marvel has had is getting
people to care about the eternals
because by and large they just seem
unnecessary right the role of the
eternals of marvel comics is to
safeguard humanity from the deviants and
whatever threats may befall the earth
from beyond the stars right
extraterrestrials different things like
that
but as time has progressed and as
humanity has grown more powerful in the
comics now you got stuff like the x-men
and x-factor and x-force and alpha
flight and omega flight and big hero 6
and the avengers and the new avengers
and the mighty avengers and west coast
avengers and all kinds of stuff right
you got all kinds of teams that exist
out there and that's to say nothing of
ultra powerful beings like hyperion and
the century or franklin richards or the
molecule man owen reese and just those
four guys their powers dwarf the powers
of the eternals themselves so by and
large there isn't a need for the
eternals to safeguard humanity from
anything because humanity can protect
itself and so ever since then no one's
really cared about the eternals because
no one's wrote a compelling story to
give people a reason to care about the
eternals so i didn't really go into this
film expecting this to basically pick up
and to correct all the mistakes that the
comics had made having said that the
movie had pluses and it had minuses just
like any movie so let's start with the
things that i loved about this so
overall just in terms of how the movie
looked not really focusing on the
character development or anything like
that but just the visual look of the
film it was gorgeous right the
soundtrack was fantastic the special
effects were mind-blowing i absolutely
loved it it just it was a visually
stunning film one of the things that i
loved the most about this and i was a
little uncertain about how it would
unfold the celestials right the
celestials
were enormous they were every bit as
imposing as you would expect them to be
right okay so let's say i'm irishm the
judge right just to give you guys
perspective let's say i'm irish and the
judge and i'm holding my hand out right
the eternals were like that tall in my
hand
[Music]
you